Of course,
I had spiritual moments in a bland sense
of that word.
And I suppose,
but I think the right sense,
I have times when I am just transported
with awe and joy and a sense of peace
and wonder at whether it's music or art
or,
or just a child playing or some other
wonderful thing off.
And my sail boat,
uh,
being amazed at the beauty of the ocean.
Uh,
I think that people make the mistake of
thinking that spirituality in that sense
has anything to do with either a
religious doctrines or with
immateriality or the supernatural.
Uh,
the world is a stunningly interesting
and glorious place and at every scale
and the are that one can experience
because one understands something about
how the parts are put together is I
think far greater than the sort of,
or of incomprehension.
Just I think,
I think it's,
the universe is much more wonderful the
more you know about how it's put
together.
Of course,
we can change our brains,
uh,
through meditation.
Uh,
um,
you can change your brain through,
through doing crossword puzzles or,
or,
or reading a novel or through meditating
or through running.
Uh,
brains are stunningly adjustable
plastic,
uh,
organs and everything you do,
it changes your brain a little bit.
Uh,
otherwise you couldn't leave a trace of
what you do.
He couldn't have any memory.
Uh,
so meditation is one actually very good
way of changing your brand.
I think meditation plays some of the
roles that are played also by sleep of
restoring balance,
uh,
getting rid of tension and access and
generally calming the whole system down
so that it can confront the world anew.
It's a sort of a refreshment.